I fairly recently learned the definition
of inel it's like a military term no no
what it means is somebody who is
invol CIB oh that's what incel means you
didn't know incel no I thought it was
like a military we got like three incels
over here in the
building it's a sophisticated word for a
guy who wants [__] he can't get it
can't get
[__] I read that you're married that's
not true I'm not where you read that I
think on Wikipedia that's not on my
Wikipedia I think it said it said that
you married one it said you married to a
dude and then another article I read
said that you were married to a girl
okay well no and I even said that to you
I was like oh I didn't know you was gay
we got a crack research department on
the Wild Ride
pod yeah I saw it somewhere you were gay
or married or something what was that
like